foreign
[Music]
every time I see a self-driving car I
can't help but wonder what kind of inner
mechanisms are at work there are many
Automotive companies today that are
pursuing self-driving a few big names
probably come to mind in this relatively
new space there are lots of challenges
coming up each day training ml models
with appropriate data sets is one of
those big challenges
so to dig deeper into this I have the
pleasure of speaking with Harrison who
is that hell may I and is helping
companies scale their capabilities with
ML models that teach themselves Harrison
thanks so much for being here could you
please tell us a little bit about
yourself and about how may I yeah thanks
for having me here today Debbie so my
name is Harrison I'm the tech lead of
the platform team at Helm AI so the
platform team is focused on building
internal infrastructure for other
engineers at home so how may I uh we're
a company or a startup that's focused on
building a vision-based perception uh
for autonomous vehicles notably we're
actually not building our own car uh we
just license software to oems and other
tier one manufacturers for vehicles and
then the thing that kind of sets Helm
apart is that we have this approach
called Deep teaching which is a
variation of unsupervised learning it
enables us to train models at much
greater scale and lower cost too
that's super interesting that how may I
is kind of thinking about this approach
a little differently and it's building
the software versus the actual car
I want to know a little bit more about
this deep teaching on supervised
learning that you mentioned could you
tell us a little bit more about that
yeah so there's basically two main
approaches one is supervised and the
other is unsupervised learning so with
supervised learning you need to get a
bunch of data so in the case of like
self-driving Vehicles we're working with
camera data so we we need a bunch of
frames and we need to like label things
in those frames so we might need to like
say you know this is a bounding box and
this inside of this bounding box is a
car
or you know we draw like a line and say
you know this is like a landmark or
something to train a model using
supervised learning we basically have to
do this for you know millions and
millions of frames
and then uh have the neural net learn
based on what the human annotations are
with unsupervised learning the idea is
that the model should be able to train
itself for the most part and then we
only need like a few labels to basically
guide that learning um so we still need
labels obviously but at a much smaller
smaller scale
and then the thing is getting labels is
actually not cheap right because you
know how can you label something
um well you need like a model that
already can identify it well we don't
have that so we need to rely on like
humans right so uh getting people to
annotate uh video frames accurately uh
and at scale is very hard uh it takes a
lot of time and money to do that you
know you can imagine we could go with
the supervised learning approach
um and train you know models that are
effective in driving cars but I think
then the question is like at what cost
you know you might end up spending a lot
of money just to uh solve new edge cases
so that makes a lot of sense so you're
saving time and money by taking the
unsupervised learning approach because
you don't have to label everything is
there like a real world example that you
would say uh to explain this
yeah so to kind of get the intuition for
this uh you can kind of think about you
know when you're a young child you don't
know a lot about the world right but
you're exposed to like a whole bunch of
different like examples of things right
so you might see like a whole bunch of
trees but not realize that they actually
are trees or that they're called trees
right and you don't need someone to come
and tell you hey this oak tree is a tree
this pine tree is also a tree you know
you can kind of see the patterns and
similarities right you learn to
recognize oh there's a trunk and there's
some leaves all it takes is for someone
to come to you one day and say like hey
this is a tree and then you realize you
know all these other things that you saw
in the past even though you didn't know
what they were called at the time now
you know that they're trees that's so
awesome it's basically like natural
learning so in addition to maybe knowing
what a tree is what other use cases uh
could this be used in
so you can take this same kind of
intuition and apply it to autonomous
vehicles so you can't uh predict
everything that's going to happen on the
road but you need to account for a lot
of these edge cases usually training for
and solving edge cases is actually the
hardest part and basically what we want
is like to train models on a whole bunch
of examples but only need to label a
small number of those edge cases
that's super interesting how the
software learns from just one label to
labeling many things that it's seen
before the software that you're that how
may I uses and has built is this limited
to cars or can it be used on other
things as well yeah that's a great
question so right now Helm is focused on
uh autonomous vehicles so everything
from L2 plus and up uh we're kind of uh
targeting vision is not something that's
limited to self-driving right we can
apply the same same principles to
robotics uh so anything that requires
like identifying objects
um via like cameras and vision like I
think that's totally within the domain
of like Helm's expertise so we actually
took a model that we trained off of a
camera on a car and put it onto a drone
and saw that it was able to identify you
know the same things roads and vehicles
even though it had never seen any Drone
footage before
wow that is mind-blowing to think about
that's so interesting so now that I
understand a little bit like how the
software Works let's talk about kind of
what's under the hood what is the
architecture of the cloud infrastructure
that's going on behind the scenes
so there are a whole bunch of like
things that the research Engineers need
to do before it even comes time to train
a model you know one of those things is
like converting all the uh sensor data
from cars into a common format you know
getting all that data labeled once it's
labeled then we finally can you know
train a model based on that data and
then afterwards we also have to validate
the results and you know make sure the
model is like actually performing well
in all sorts of scenarios and so
everything I kind of described just now
is actually you can think of it as like
a data transformation right you take
sensor data convert it into label data
you know that sort of stuff or you take
labeled data and you convert it into a
model that can you know recognize those
those objects so what we did at home was
we built out uh some like generic
infrastructure uh using Google
kubernetes engine so we have a cluster
that we can use uh for just running
anything on the cloud uh obviously the
reason we you know need it on the cloud
is because we're we're working with a
lot of data so it's not feasible for us
to have all the compute and memory you
know resources uh locally or like in the
office right we built out a super simple
like uh solution to the problem at hand
which was we just want to be able to run
arbitrary code on the cluster so the
first thing we did was we said okay so
research Engineers are going to write
the actual code that has the logic uh
and these are called like jobs or tasks
and then the research Engineers can take
these jobs and send them to a scheduler
these schedulers put the jobs into like
a database so that we can keep track of
everything
and then R and rgke cluster we have uh
like job workers that will go and pull
jobs and just do them so these workers
are also preemptable so like if one of
the workers dies another one will take
its place and just uh finish the job for
it yeah and so there's also a whole
bunch of other things that we need to
build uh to kind of support this sort of
operation so one of the things like an
auto scaler that will you know scale up
the the different nodes so after the
worker uh takes the job and uh kind of
does whatever needs to be done uh the
outputs can be stored in like Google
Cloud Storage or even Cloud SQL kind of
depending on the needs so it's like a
very generic infrastructure to just run
arbitrary code on the cluster you know
read data also from the cloud and output
data into the cloud
that makes sense can you
go into how you landed on this
particular design
so when we kind of originally built this
out you know Helm was a very uh early
stage startup
and we were really just focused on
building out the bare minimum to get
things done right you know we didn't try
to do anything extremely sophisticated
like when the research Engineers write
their code you know we just take the
whole thing the whole uh their whole
workspace like repository we just
archive it and just upload it to the
cloud like we didn't try to do anything
fancy uh there and then another big
thing for us was like we really needed
to process a lot of data and keep the
costs low right so as a startup you know
we don't have a lot of cash so we have
to make sure that you know every penny
counts so that's why we're using
preemptable instances uh it helps us a
lot with cost and we actually have uh
we actually have multiple clusters so we
basically just took the same uh design
and we deployed it multiple times into
different regions uh obviously like if
we were to go back and redo it like it
would be great if we just had a single
scheduler and then like the work could
be done in any cluster
um but the simplest thing to do at the
time was you know just take the thing
that we built and was working and just
scale It Up by duplicating it and that's
kind of how we just like uh tackled the
quickly growing like uh needs of the
company that makes sense based on your
business needs you make the decisions
you need to for the architecture so I
see you're also using some other Google
Cloud products can you tell us a little
bit about those
so to kind of give an example our
customers are often curious like how our
Nets are performing in various different
uh conditions so like they often want to
know you know how's it doing in day
daytime versus night time or you know
different weather conditions like Sun
versus rain and they're also often
curious about like how we're performing
on very specific cases so like how are
we doing for you know trucks or versus
sedans or bicycles and motorcycles and
so being able to use bigquery uh is
really great for this where we can just
kind of slice and dice by any sort of
like Dimension that we care about and
then the other thing is data Studio
which integrates really well with this
is like we can build uh dashboards with
like graphs and charts with all this
information and just very easily be able
to like glance at it after training and
say you know these are all the things we
care about and they you know they still
look good for for the model that's
really interesting to hear how you're
using bigquery and data Studio along
with some other Google cloud services so
I'm curious to know if you ran into any
challenges while you you were
implementing these services and how you
dealt with them yeah I think definitely
the two biggest challenges were like uh
working with a lot of data and keeping
costs low because these things often
don't go hand in hand how much data
would you say you were working with and
how did you manage that yeah so we're
working on uh the order of like
petabytes of data and obviously as home
grows and matures as a company we're
only going to be working with more and
more
as one of the things that we did was we
built our data Lake using Google Cloud
Storage
um so basically all of our data is in
here and it just makes it a lot easier
when everything is like stored on the
same uh in this in the same place to
kind of like find data more easily we
built like a whole bunch of like
queryable indexes and Google Cloud SQL
so you know oftentimes we want to be
able to find very specific videos or
models or data and so we built a whole
bunch of databases to kind of like
organize ourselves to organize all the
data that we do store in the cloud and
of course you know we have other UI
tools that we built in-house to like
View and modify data so one of them is
just like a video server where you can
play back videos that you generated or
like another one is to be able to view
labeled data and modify and tweak it and
then another big thing is we have an
archive Daemon that just runs
periodically and takes any uh any data
that's like older than a few months and
we just like put it into archive storage
to save on cost wow okay so that's a lot
of stuff being managed you mentioned
that you know as you continue to grow
you'll probably have more data so your
architecture might change a little are
there any other future technical
enhancements to your architecture that
might come up there's definitely many
things that we want to get done as a
company
um and all of it is going to be a
trade-off you know between short and
long-term commitments
um I think one of the things that we're
kind of eager to do eventually is like
to take advantage of the multi-region
capabilities of Google Cloud so one of
the things I mentioned before was like
we basically took our design and to
scale it up we just basically duplicated
it in different regions researchers have
to submit their jobs to very specific
places like they need to know you know
how much work is being done on a
particular cluster allocate their their
jobs accordingly right they have to like
coordinate between each other to figure
out where they should submit their jobs
obviously this is an ideal like I think
it would be much better you know if
everyone could just submit their jobs to
the same place and then the
infrastructure and the system can take
care of you know load balancing and
scale in that sense uh one of the other
things that we definitely want to do
better at is like our data Lake
organization
um so I think right now we're doing okay
but one of the things that's kind of
unique about our space is that there's
like a lot of different versions of data
so
uh for example like
once we bring in customer data it's
actually we can't just like train a
model directly on that oftentimes we
have to convert convert the data into a
common format so one of the things is
like rectification and so this is highly
dependent on you know camera parameters
that we get from the customer and a lot
of times there's just things like Lost
in Translation where it's like oh yeah
sorry we actually sent you the wrong
camera parameters so uh can you just
like redo everything using the new ones
right and so you might have to like
retrain your model relabel the data uh
you know these sorts of things where it
just like generates a new version of the
same stuff uh so ideally we you know
want to have a better solution around
how we're managing all these different
versions of the data as well as just the
sheer scale of the data that makes a lot
of sense so you're dealing with a lot of
data organization is key
Harrison thank you so much for being
here today and for talking to us about
how may I and the magic that goes on uh
where can people go to learn more yeah
thanks so much for having me here today
Debbie uh so we have a website with a
jobs page if you're interested in home
uh also there's a LinkedIn and blog
there as well well now next time I see a
self-driving car I know some of the
magic more Ai and machine learning
that's happening under the hood as
always if you're interested in learning
more check out the links in the
description that Harrison mentioned And
subscribe for more great customer
stories thanks for watching
foreign
[Music]